en junio de 2020 vino a defender la
causa de las cuidadoras a domicilio
un año después casting lohan sigue
movilizada para las personas mayores
en este pueblo 17 personas murieron de
covite remy logró recuperarse después de
enfermar en marzo de 2020
afortunadamente no desarrolló una forma
muy grave de covite en comparación con
migo
pero bueno está bien está bien en marzo
de 2020 sin acceso a tapabocas katrin
contrajo el virus y lo transmitió a su
marido que pasó 12 días hospitalizado
retomó el trabajo pero sigue sin poder
organizar comidas o salidas en grupo
algo que raquel de 97 años la menta
tenemos suerte de tenerlas si no fuera
por ellas qué haríamos estaría en una
residencia y yo no tengo ganas de ir a
una residencia
quizás llegará el día en que será
necesario pero espero que sea lo más
tarde posible 27 horas a la semana
pagadas con el salario mínimo
condiciones que no han cambiado por la
pandemia
no tenemos ningún reconocimiento tampoco
salarial
el gobierno promete un aumento de sueldo
en octubre mientras tanto katrin y sus
compañeras esperan que la crisis
sanitaria haya ayudado a visibilizar y a
reconocer su profesión